so it's Monday evening tonight I want to
talk about two benchmarks that were
published just last week they're very
similar in some way and I think this
might be the future of how we Benchmark
Frontiers model let's start with the
first one called Gia it's a general it's
a benchmark for General AI assistance
it's collaboration between Fair one of
my team at hugy face clementin and also
o to GPT Greg sft this Benchmark is here
to investigate
General assistant which is it's pretty
clear today that in the future we'll
have ai that are able to do many things
for us right that are able to go on the
web to take a look at picture to hear a
sound and to combine all the source of
information plus some reflection some
coding to give us the answer to the
question that we're asking okay let's
say I'm listening to radio hear the
sound of a band the AI can also hear
this name um and can basically take a
look on the the web and add this to my
Spotify G take this to a much higher
level there is three levels in Gaia
level three is almost impossible for GPT
Pro today level one has 30% success
level one an example of question of
level one is like this okay what was the
actual enrollment count of the clinical
trial on hpor in acne vulgaris patient
from January to May 2018 as listed an
NIH website the model need to be able to
go on the web find the NIH website look
at for the the right clinical trial and
basically find the answer okay not so
difficult now level three is a whole
other story here is a level three
question in NASA's Astronomy Picture of
the Day in 2006 January 21 two
astronauts are visible a large one a
small one take the smallest one find the
astronaut's groups that it was a member
of and find in his group which astronaut
spend the least amount of time in space
now give me the number of minutes round
it to the nearest Minute this is
question with only just one factual
answer no ambiguity it's not super
complex to understand any human can do
that but it's very difficult level gbt 4
has almost zero level of success there
okay the IDE is to take this fundament
is to test this fundamental capabilities
without any
ambiguity GP QA is the second bench Mark
also 30% success of gp4 almost the same
number of question 450 also a name with
which is an acronym starting with a g on
four letterers that's all the all the
similarities other than that is very
different and the reason gp4 find this
this this uh Benchmark very difficult is
that it's designed to be at the limit of
human knowledge okay this is a data set
where each question was created by
someone who has a PhD in physics
chemistry or
biology and these question are all
crafted so that a non expert will get
will won't be able to get to the to the
right answer right but these are still
question that at the limit of knowledge
so that there can be another PhD student
pair that can check and for each case
there were at least one other expert who
check that the answer was true so the
same in both of these case we have
factually true answers okay but here
give me let me give you an example with
are very different type of an answer
let's take quantum mechanics because
that's what I used to do before I like
suppose we have a theorizing channel
operation given by E the probability of
the deiz theorization state represent
the the strength of the noise if the
close operator of the given states are
have a set of close operator accretion
what could be the correct cross
representation of the states this is
very complex question and the reason
this question I designed so is is that
this Benchmark the goal is not to test
the general AI assistant it's to test
narrow superhuman AI okay these are AI
which will be better than human at some
task we already have that with for
instance go right but we may have that
soon as well for like physics Discovery
right what happen if the AI create a new
physics theory how can you check this is
true we have a we have a set of theories
we have like debates we have some ideas
on how to check and design this but we
we need a benchmark to be able to
Benchmark this series we need a
benchmark to be able to test what is
called scal SC scalable
oversight and this is the idea of this
Benchmark okay in both case this is a
small set of question
450 carefully designed one by one by
humans carefully crafted one by one
they're almost impossible to memorize
okay and also impossible to find by a
simple Google search in all of these
case I would say memorization as has
make no sense because the answer is not
what's important it's not you know what
was the name of this astronaut that's
important it's not what is the cross
operator that's important what will be
important for us will be how the model
what is the trace how the model reason
and use the tools to be able to reach to
this to reach this answer okay uh in
both cases also we are huge combinator
of spaces here we're exploring the web
we're using tools this is just huge
Comin natural space of action the model
can do a lot of things the same here we
in the full Comin natural space of human
knowledge Theory okay everything is
possible basically this is really where
we want to test the models now because
pure memorization doesn't really make
any more sense to test okay and I think
in both case what I like the most and
what I love the most that these are open
source openly shared Benchmark with the
communities not something that's just
developed in private lab right but
things that we'll be able to use as
common grounds to compare various models
together okay and things that we'll be
able to build upon so that's what made
me maybe the most excited about these
two new
papers